foreign
[Music]
about the impossibility of love and the
aim for finding home I was moved by Lee
and Marin's story they're both Outsiders
and I think that was relevant to all
this Marin this is a sheltered kid who
doesn't really know what she is she's
trying to figure it out and Lee seems to
have so many answers of how to live with
who they are I don't want to hurt
anybody everyone's got their rules
that's not one of my rules
he's trying to make her feel like she
can accept who she is and she doesn't
need a change we gotta do this we have
to do it in life there are things that
burn people that they shouldn't be
burdened with and then this film we see
two people that are not only safe from
each other but really in love and
comforted by one another
[Music]
the impossibility that Marin and Lee
face are a cinematic reflection of all
the impossibilities that build us as
people they definitely become a family I
think that's one of the most beautiful
parts of it I would have done the same
thing
you protected the people that you lost
know somebody fully to see all their
ugly stuff and love them for who they
are I think that's pretty rare
what did you do
I ate them right now
and it felt great